It's a ridiculously complicated machine that does something really simple,
like crack an egg or shut a door.
Well, it kind of reminds me of the financial services industry,
honestly.
I mean, you tap your card in the corner store,
and a bitstream goes through a dozen companies,
each with their own computer system,
some of them being 1970s mainframes
older than many of the people in this room,
and three days later, a settlement occurs.
Well, with a blockchain financial industry,
there would be no settlement,
because the payment and the settlement is the same activity,
it's just a change in the ledger.
So Wall Street and all around the world,
the financial industry is in a big upheaval about this,
wondering, can we be replaced,
or how do we embrace this technology for success?
Now, why should you care?
Well, let me describe some applications.
Prosperity.
The first era of the internet,
the internet of information,
brought us wealth but not shared prosperity,
because social inequality is growing.
And this is at the heart of all of the anger and extremism
and protectionism and xenophobia and worse
that we're seeing growing in the world today,
Brexit being the most recent case.
So could we develop some new approaches to this problem of inequality?
Because the only approach today is to redistribute wealth,
tax people and spread it around more.
Could we pre-distribute wealth?
Could we change the way that wealth gets created in the first place
by democratizing wealth creation,
engaging more people in the economy,
and then ensuring that they got fair compensation?
Let me describe five ways that this can be done.
Number one:
Did you know that 70 percent of the people in the world who have land
have a tenuous title to it?
So, you've got a little farm in Honduras, some dictator comes to power,
he says, "I know you've got a piece of paper that says you own your farm,
but the government computer says my friend owns your farm."
This happened on a mass scale in Honduras,
and this problem exists everywhere.
Hernando de Soto, the great Latin American economist,
says this is the number one issue in the world
in terms of economic mobility,
more important than having a bank account,
because if you don't have a valid title to your land,
you can't borrow against it,
and you can't plan for the future.
So today, companies are working with governments
to put land titles on a blockchain.
And once it's there, this is immutable.
You can't hack it.
This creates the conditions for prosperity
for potentially billions of people.
Secondly:
a lot of writers talk about Uber
and Airbnb and TaskRabbit and Lyft and so on
as part of the sharing economy.
This is a very powerful idea,
that peers can come together and create and share wealth.
My view is that ...
these companies are not really sharing.
In fact, they're successful precisely because they don't share.
They aggregate services together, and they sell them.
What if, rather than Airbnb being a $25 billion corporation,
there was a distributed application on a blockchain, we'll call it B-Airbnb,
and it was essentially owned by all of the people
who have a room to rent.
And when someone wants to rent a room,
they go onto the blockchain database and all the criteria,
they sift through, it helps them find the right room,
and then the blockchain helps with the contracting,
it identifies the party,
it handles the payments
just through digital payments -- they're built into the system.
And it even handles reputation,
because if she rates a room as a five-star room,
that room is there,
and it's rated, and it's immutable.
So, the big sharing-economy disruptors in Silicon Valley
could be disrupted,
and this would be good for prosperity.
Number three:
the biggest flow of funds from the developed world
to the developing world
is not corporate investment,
and it's not even foreign aid.
It's remittances.
This is the global diaspora;
people have left their ancestral lands,
and they're sending money back to their families at home.
This is 600 billion dollars a year, and it's growing,
and these people are getting ripped off.
Analie Domingo is a housekeeper.
She lives in Toronto,
and every month she goes to the Western Union office
with some cash
to send her remittances to her mom in Manila.
It costs her around 10 percent;
the money takes four to seven days to get there;
her mom never knows when it's going to arrive.
It takes five hours out of her week to do this.
Six months ago,
Analie Domingo used a blockchain application called Abra.
And from her mobile device, she sent 300 bucks.
It went directly to her mom's mobile device
without going through an intermediary.
And then her mom looked at her mobile device --
it's kind of like an Uber interface, there's Abra "tellers" moving around.
She clicks on a teller that's a five-star teller,
who's seven minutes away.
The guy shows up at the door, gives her Filipino pesos,
she puts them in her wallet.
The whole thing took minutes,
and it cost her two percent.
This is a big opportunity for prosperity.
Number four: the most powerful asset of the digital age is data.
And data is really a new asset class,
maybe bigger than previous asset classes,
like land under the agrarian economy,
or an industrial plant,
or even money.
And all of you -- we -- create this data.
We create this asset,
and we leave this trail of digital crumbs behind us
as we go throughout life.
And these crumbs are collected into a mirror image of you,
the virtual you.
And the virtual you may know more about you than you do,
because you can't remember what you bought a year ago,
or said a year ago, or your exact location a year ago.
And the virtual you is not owned by you --
that's the big problem.
So today, there are companies working
to create an identity in a black box,
the virtual you owned by you.
And this black box moves around with you
as you travel throughout the world,
and it's very, very stingy.
It only gives away the shred of information
that's required to do something.
A lot of transactions,
the seller doesn't even need to know who you are.
They just need to know that they got paid.
And then this avatar is sweeping up all of this data
and enabling you to monetize it.
And this is a wonderful thing,
because it can also help us protect our privacy,
and privacy is the foundation of a free society.
Let's get this asset that we create
back under our control,
where we can own our own identity
and manage it responsibly.
Finally --
(Applause)
Finally, number five:
there are a whole number of creators of content
who don't receive fair compensation,
because the system for intellectual property is broken.
It was broken by the first era of the internet.
Take music.
Musicians are left with crumbs at the end of the whole food chain.
You know, if you were a songwriter, 25 years ago, you wrote a hit song,
it got a million singles,
you could get royalties of around 45,000 dollars.
Today, you're a songwriter, you write a hit song,
it gets a million streams,
you don't get 45k,
you get 36 dollars,
enough to buy a nice pizza.
So Imogen Heap,
the Grammy-winning singer-songwriter,
is now putting music on a blockchain ecosystem.
She calls it "Mycelia."
And the music has a smart contract surrounding it.
And the music protects her intellectual property rights.
You want to listen to the song?
It's free, or maybe a few micro-cents that flow into a digital account.
You want to put the song in your movie, that's different,
and the IP rights are all specified.
You want to make a ringtone? That's different.
She describes that the song becomes a business.
It's out there on this platform marketing itself,
protecting the rights of the author,
and because the song has a payment system
in the sense of bank account,
all the money flows back to the artist,
and they control the industry,
rather than these powerful intermediaries.
Now, this is --
(Applause)
This is not just songwriters,
it's any creator of content,
like art,
like inventions,
scientific discoveries, journalists.
There are all kinds of people who don't get fair compensation,
and with blockchains,
they're going to be able to make it rain on the blockchain.
And that's a wonderful thing.
So, these are five opportunities
out of a dozen
to solve one problem, prosperity,
which is one of countless problems
that blockchains are applicable to.
Now, technology doesn't create prosperity, of course -- people do.
But my case to you is that, once again,
the technology genie has escaped from the bottle,
and it was summoned by an unknown person or persons
at this uncertain time in human history,
and it's giving us another kick at the can,
another opportunity to rewrite the economic power grid
and the old order of things,
and solve some of the world's most difficult problems,
if we will it.
Thank you.
(Applause)